dass der Industriestandort Deutschland
gefährdet ist was ja auch wieder und
sogar nicht nur Industrie aber vor allem
Industrie aber der Wirtschaftsstandort
insgesamt und da fängt nämlich die die
Problemlage fängt ja nicht erst beim
Blackout an das ist eben genau das was
ich hier vorhin auch schon gesagt habe
die letzte Agentur wird unter Umständen
im Winter das wird auch offen so
kommuniziert gezwungen sein große
Abnehmer vorher mit Ansage abzunehmen
das ist für die Unternehmen nicht so
katastrophal wie ein plötzliches aus das
Strom und Gaszufuhr aber es ist
natürlich auch für den
Wirtschaftsstandorten extremer schaden
also jetzt war ja gerade in dieser Woche
der arbeitgebertag in Berlin es herrscht
Panik das kann man sagen bei denen bei
den Mittelständlern vor allem aber auch
in
bis hin zu den großen dass die einfach
teilweise merken sie kriegen keine
Versorgungsverträge mehr den werden die
Stromverträge
nicht und die sind nicht wie Privatleute
dann geschützt in solchen Situationen
sondern die müssen sich umgucken was
neues zu kriegen wir hatten vorher schon
in Deutschland die höchsten Strompreise
Europas jetzt sind die plötzlich
versetztfacht verachtfach das heißt das
sind richtige existenznöter und wenn
dann auch noch die Gefahr einer
Abschaltung dazu kommt dann werden
einige das diesen Winter nicht
überstehen können und der Staat ist
endlich in seiner Finanzierung er
verspricht jetzt sehr viel
im Sommer ist er auch schon für für
Verbraucher für Arbeitnehmer für jetzt
für Rentner
in die in die Vollen gegangen und hat
Geld verteilt das kann man nicht endlos
machen wir haben das in der corona-zeit
gemacht was jetzt an Hilfen vielleicht
nötig sein wird weil es geht nicht um
einzelne Branchen es geht um weite Teile
unserer Industrie Unternehmens darf ich
Sie bitten hier einmal dass wir einmal
konkret noch mal werden sind der
Chefökonomen und promoide Volkswirte wie
viele Arbeitsplätze sind denn gefährdet
in diesem Land also die Industrie
beschäftigt
gut 7 Millionen Jobs die sind nicht alle
weg dann das ist ein schleichender
Prozess der hat auch schon angefangen
der ist eben auch gerade wegen der
Energiewende auch schon seit Jahren im
Gang und beschleunigt sich gerade also
die Chemieindustrie ist beispielsweise
in diesem Jahr zehn Prozent mit ihrer
Produktion runtergegangen und die waren
noch nicht auf vor corona-niveau
in welcher Rangordnung sprechen wir naja
jetzt ist kurzarbeitergeldregelung schon
wieder verlängert worden also man wird
versuchen sie zu retten nur die die
Wahrscheinlichkeit wenn wir nicht mit
der Energiewende uns ehrlich machen und
sagen wir brauchen länger deutlich
länger als das was jetzt als Planung da
ist
genau sein aber über wie viele Jobs
reden wir reden wir über 10.000 oder
100.000 Millionen worüber reden wir wenn
wir sagen müssen
die die Energiepreise mit diesem Niveau
ist unsere Industrie fast komplett tot
und an unserer Industrie hängt auch das
Handwerk zum großen Teil weil das was im
Privaträumen gemacht wird der kleinere
Anteil ist aber es geht auch um den
ganzen auch im Dienstleistungsbereiche
weil wo wird Dienstleistungen gemacht
das ist in vielen Bereichen ist das
zusammen es hängt zusammen weil wir
Wertschöpfungsketten haben die nicht nur
Industriebetrieb denn darstellen das
sind ganze Ortschaften die hängen an
bestimmten Unternehmen wo dann eben wenn
da die Lichter ausgehen halt auch der
Bäcker um die Ecke nichts mehr verkauft
und das Restaurant dicht machen muss
also es ist die gesamte Wirtschaft die
sich um bei uns einem starken
industriellen
Lärm eigentlich
insgesamt bildet und das ungefähr 25
Prozent unserer Wertschöpfung während
von diesen 7,5 Millionen
Arbeitnehmern erwirtschaftet ist der
kleinere Teil zu sagen das ist kurz vor
zwölf eine Minute Nacht und die bringen
ungefähr 40 Prozent der Sozialabgaben
also auch die Rente ist da nicht mehr zu
zahlen also es gibt sozusagen
interessanterweise aber das Problem
Angela Merkels Politikstil hat Ihnen
gefallen den mache ich auch
sagen aber das was wir jetzt an
Strompreisen sehen wird die
Arbeitslosigkeit wieder dahin bringen wo
sie bei Gerhard Schröder war
und sie kann auch noch weiter steigen
weil es wird davon ab wie lange es
dauert und wie man dann damit umgehen
wird das ist schwer vorher zu sein aber
400 Euro pro mehr wattstunde Stromkosten
ist nicht vertragbar für die deutsche
Wirtschaft sind sie auch alarmiert ich
bin extrem alarmiert was die deutsche
Wirtschaft antrifft
und
das Signal wir tun zuerst was für die
Bürger kann ich zwar inhaltlich
irgendwie verstehen von der Regierung
aber sozusagen erst muss man mal sagen
dass der Laden hier am Laufen bleibt und
dann können wir gucken wie wir mit
denjenigen die das sich nicht leisten
können was tun muss also ich hätte es
jedenfalls mindestens gleichzeitig
gemacht oder haben wir es bei Corona
damals ja auch gemacht wir haben sowohl
Pakete für die damals Betroffene
Wirtschaft gemacht und in der
Finanzkrise auch dass wir den Motor den
unser Land hier zusammenhält nicht
stützen weil das würde ganz sicher in
der läuft ganz sicher heißt wenn ich in
diesem Beispiel bleiben darf und ich bin
jetzt ja hier nicht als aller Mist
grundsätzlich aufgetreten aber
ich hoffe dass dann Warnung
glaubwürdiger ist weil ich nicht bei
jedem Thema gleich sage steht die
unmittelbare Katastrophe davor aber das
ist für die deutsche Wirtschaft so nicht
verkraftbar und deswegen ist die
Regierung da gefordert dass sie jetzt
gar nichts mehr tun will kann überhaupt
nicht vorstellen aber es muss auch sehr
rechtzeitig passieren weil die
Unternehmen haben ja zum Teil den
Schaden schon die haben sich ja schon
für 2023 wird Strom Verträgen und zahlen
das Fünffache und das ist
wäre eine Minute nach genau 12 ja ist
ganz einfach erklärt die Politik hat ja
jede Menge Kraftwerke schon abgeschaltet
und es ist halt nicht damit getan dass
man die wieder anschaltet weil war warum
wurden die abgeschaltet es gab Pläne die
Kraftwerke abzuschalten und die Ampel
hat ja auch gesagt wir ziehen den
Kohleausstieg von 2038 auf 20 30 vor was
macht denn jemand der ein Kraftwerk hat
und weiß dass das demnächst abgeschaltet
wird renoviert er das noch so oder setze
das so in stand dass es 30 Jahre
weiterlaufen kann oder macht er nur
notdürftige Reparaturen also was wir
haben ist ganz einfach wir haben einen
überalterten Kraftwerkspark der zu ab
schon vorgesehen war das heißt uns
fehlen neue Kraftwerke und neues
Kraftwerk zu bauen ist das Gaskraftwerk
ist das schnellste fünf bis sieben Jahre
nach Genehmigung und dann kommen die
Kohlekraftwerke und dann die
Kernkraftwerke Kernkraft ist ja hier
sowieso das Böse da wird also gar nichts
passieren aber wer das die effektivste
Energieversorgung für unser Land dann
haben wir momentan das ist nicht die
teuerste Kinder die Investition für das
Kernkraftwerk ist teuer ja aber dafür
läuft das Ding auch 60 Jahre und wenn
man jetzt nicht politisch vorgeführt
wenn man nicht politisch vorgefärbte
Meinung hat dann ist die Kernkraft auch
günstig so das aber ganz egal wir haben
einfach so
ja aber sonst machen keine Kraftwerke da
sind und wir haben eine gewisse für zehn
Jahre weil einfach wir müssen neue
Kraftwerke bauen
es stimmt natürlich dass es
subventioniert wird und dass es stark
subventioniert wird vom Staat also das
Kraftwerk in Europa das nicht mehr 20
Milliarden gekostet haben
stimmt nicht aber weltweit gibt es immer
mehr Kernkraft und die Pläne
bei der Bevölkerung auch an als man eben
die Angst vor der Kernkraft oder
Atomkraft vorangetrieben